silvester meine damen und herren war
böllerverbot aber die europäische union
hat am 31 12 trotzdem einen echten
knaller gezündet mit einem brief an die
mitgliedstaaten wo drin stand guten
rutsch allerseits und bevor wir es
vergessen atomkraft ist bald grün ach ja
und gas übrigens auch da geht es um die
sogenannte taxonomie idee dahinter
investoren helfen geld nachhaltig
anzulegen um damit klimaschutz
voranzutreiben wenn also gas und atom
jetzt auch nachhaltig sind hat man diese
ideen ihr exaktes gegenteil verkehrt
warum sollte man kernkraft grün
anpinseln wir deutschen schalten noch
bis ende dieses jahres alle akw s ab in
unserer beliebten rolle als vorbild für
alle europäischen nachbarn und mal ganz
ehrlich zu sein ich kann nicht verstehen
wie man so dumm sein kann dass man seine
eigenen atommeiler abgeschaltet die voll
funktionsfähig sind
also ich spreche leider kein slowakisch
aber ich meine der hat uns eben durch
genannt fürs protokoll nicht mal die
kernkraftbetreiber wollen bei uns eine
laufzeitverlängerung weil es sich
schlicht nicht rechnet und weil
nachhaltige atomkraft müssten
energiekonzerne wenigstens auch risiken
und folgekosten übernehmen fukushima hat
geschätzte 500 milliarden gekostet meine
was stimmt wegen unserer verrückten und
viel zu langsam energiewende brauchen
wir in deutschland wohl gas als
übergangstechnologie
das ging ja auch ohne grün
etikettenschwindel ernsthaft wenn atom
und gas nachhaltig sind dann ist alles
nachhaltig da kommt dann machen wir das
jetzt so warum nicht kreuzfahrten ab
sofort nachhaltig denen kreuzfahrten auf
dem wasser statt und wasser ist leben
massentierhaltung voll nachhaltig denn
kühe sind ja vegetarier oder über 400
fahren auf der a2 wie dieser
tschechischen millionär neulich ist
total nachhaltig weil die
umweltverschmutzung ist dann ja viel
schneller vorbei verstehen sie
wie freuen sich wegen der umwelt sehr
klar man in wirklichkeit geht es hier
übrigens nur darum einen fast bankrotten
französischen atomkonzern zu retten herr
makro braucht das für seinen wahlkampf
weil rund 70% des französischen stroms
nuklear sind dann haben die deutschen
gesagt hör moment wenn die schnecken
lutscher ihr grünes atom kriegen wollen
wir aber grünes gas sind klassischer eu
kompromiss 2 scheiße ideen wir machen
beide und natürlich wieder mit strengen
auflagen für die atomkraftwerke die das
begehrte öko siegel wollen laut dem eu
vorschlag müssen diese den neuesten
technischen standards entsprechen und
ein konkreter plan für den betrieb eine
entsorgungsanlage für hochradioaktive
abfälle ab spätestens 2050 vorgelegt
werden das hat brett harte deadline bis
2050 findet ihr ein endlager bis dahin
tun wir so als hätte er schon 1
langfristige kaum zu erreichen dabei
ehrgeizige ziele das ist der neue trend
ja überall wohin guckst eine
chronische nörgler könnten einwerfen
dass im letzten dezember bis zu 17
antike französische akw s wegen wartung
oder mängeln abgeschaltet waren aber für
echte ernstfälle gibt es ja erprobte
sicherheitskonzepte wie zb hier in
gundremmingen b strahlen gefahr wird mit
diesen knüpfen eine sirene ausgelöst und
wenn es brennt
[Musik]
dann fährt bäckermeister berchtold als
feuermelder durchs dorf gundremmingen
und bläst alarm
war schön geht heute nicht mehr denn da
schlägt der fachkräftemangel leider
doppelt zu es gibt in deutschland kaum
noch bäcker und immer weniger gute
trompeter der weit die ampel wahlweise
empört oder überrascht wegen taxonomie
oder zeigt mit dem finger auf brüssel
dabei ist das genauso zwischen den
herren marco und scholz ausgekungelt
worden da wird sich unser neuer
superminister habeck noch allerhand
unangenehme fragen anhören müssen da hab
ich sie nennen ihr neues klimaschutz
ministerium zuweilen einen schlafenden
drachen fürchten sie dass dieser drache
der jetzt nun aufwachen und losfliegen
soll den menschen angst einjagen könnte
nein das ist ein ganz lieber drache so
ähnlich widersacher fuhr
ein ganz lieber drache wird jetzt sogar
als kinderbuch rausgebracht der liebe
drache robert ist ganz toll da hüpft der
liebe drache rover durch ganz
deutschland und pflanzt überall
windräder und wenn mal kein sind ist
dann pustet der liebe drache so alber
drache eines tages kam der robert in
einem bundesland fast ganz ohne
windräder
was ist denn hier los warum keine
windräder weil das für bayern ist
ökologisch wir machen nicht nur dem
quatsch wir machen strom aus kuhscheiße
und so lernte denn liebe drache robert
den bösen drachen markus kennen
ende
ja das wird derzeit der nächsten monate
schafft es der robert den markus zur
windkraft zu zwingen
leider leider wimmelt es in der
deutschen energiepolitik von lebenslügen
denn natürlich haben wir auch in den
letzten jahren atomstrom unter anderem
aus frankreich importiert immer wieder
und der gilt dann demnächst auch noch
als grün den alten aufkleber ihren wir
sind noch den alten aufträgen muss man
dringend redaktionell bearbeitet
atomkraft nein danke es sei denn wir
haben zu wenig regenerative energie und
brauchen da sie ja der franzosen für
unsere gaskraftwerke dann können wir
leider auch nichts machen ja es ist
nicht leicht für die grünen in der ampel
nicht leicht die müssen echt mehr kröten
schlucken als sie jemals über die straße
getragen haben in vier bundesländern
wird in diesem jahr gewählt da kann man
sich ungefähr vorstellen was da so
abgeht an der grünen basis
martin klempnow leitet einen kleinen
grünen ortsverband im saarland dass
atomkraft und gas jetzt grün sind
schlägt hohe wellen leute leute leute
bitte jetzt kommt mal wieder runter das
ist halt so wenn man regiert da gehören
kompromisse einfach dazu ja und wir
dürfen nicht immer in der vergangenheit
leben obwohl rück abzuschätzen ob er
zwei damals im wendland
dass die bullen mit dem wasser mehr von
unseren hollandrädern gepostet haben ja
[Gelächter]
in kraft treten
soll das heißt nach vorne gucken sie
sind immer noch bündnis 90 die grünen
die partei die deutschland transformiert
und da ist es einfach wichtig dass nicht
ihr
volker das ist jetzt bitte kein
schnitzelbrötchen was du da frisst ich
habe schon immer gehasst und jetzt ist
doch auch gut volker ja das mit der
atomkraft ist scheiße aber dafür haben
wir doch schon viele andere tolle sachen
hingekriegt in der ampel oder zum
beispiel zb
auch an dem info ständen im
straßenwahlkampf geraten die grünen in
diesen tagen immer mehr in die defensive
in baden württemberg wo ihr regiert
wurden im letzten jahr gerade mal 28
windräder gebaut und in schleswig
holstein hat landwirtschaftsminister den
abschuss von wölfen erlaubt das war
totaler quatsch das stimmt doch gar
nicht wer doch das stimme und ihr habt
den bundesrat mit getragen dass man
schweine noch bis zu 15 jahre lang in
winzigen kastenständen halten darf das
hast du doch gerade ausgedacht
das stimmt aber
bitte nicht vergessen haben 27 märz die
grünen will
doch alles nicht wahr sein was robert
habeck streicht fördermittel für
energieeffizientes bauen
kein bock mehr auf die ganze scheiße
sagt man dem volk haben wir brauchen
neuen harbeck aufsteller wo ist mir
eigentlich
volker
[Musik]
und stehe ich richtig super also dann
los
liebe fans der feinsten unterhaltung
klickt hier hin wenn ihr weitere videos
sehen wollt
das war super trägt wir haben es euch
sie auch echt schläge aus heute